I wrist bones below my thumbs still hurt pretty bad
Even the skin hurts
My fingers are stiff and my thumbs lock up every morning when I wake up
I bought a new thumbs CMC restriction split and I've been worried for one day
So not sure how much it is helping I take a lot of tumeric poliolytic enzymes and even when I was taking
800 milligrams of ibuprofen three times a day after surgery had no effect on this I tried to CBD
Typically it also DMSO is there something I'm missing a supplement maybe a rife program while I'm watching TV or something
Is it a lack of estrogen from the horrible blockers causing the tendinous or the aerobotase inhibitors?
They have ward off since I have not had an injection over two months and I'll longer have hot flashes
So I would say they've ward off in your estrogen your healthy estrogens are coming back in the balance
But the pain is not diminished yet. Maybe it takes longer. Thanks. So
With anything my first thing is we got to you got to try to figure out why right so why do you have this?
If it was from a restriction of estrogen
Yeah, that's not something that I've heard of as having, you know
Musculoskeletal type pain from the restriction of estrogen
So I don't think it was from the aroma taste inhibitor
Is it from the chemotherapy drug?
Probably so there's plenty
Documentation that people therapy drugs could give you
Hand in foot syndrome, which is really a peripheral neuropathy type situation where the chemotherapy medication damages the nerves
so
That's probably what it was
So underopathy so a neuropathy is when
The a ferret pathway of the nerve is damaged. So a ferret pathway of an herb is the
Derb that carries sensory input back to the brain
What carries motor import put back to the muscle is the e ferret pathway. So that's your brain telling your muscle to contract
But would you feel pain numbness tingling vibration hot and cold?
those are carried
from the tissue site back to the brain
So you have different receptors in your skin for those things you have different receptors in your joints you have receptors in your
subcutaneous fat layer so that when you touch a stove and you feel heat it fires
And there are back to the brain and tells the brain in the right aloe that there's heat and then that fires an herb to the frontal lobe telling you there's heat
And then your brain processes that and fires an a fer an a ferret
Signaled to the muscle to jerk your head away from that stove or hope of that own of danger
So what a reflex is is a reflex
picks up a
Sensory input and it goes only back to the cord does not go back to the brain and fires back to the e ferret pathway and jerks that their back. So you do have certain reflexes too
Now
neuropathy is when something damages the Derb so
The most common form of neuropathy is diabetic neuropathy
So it's a increased glucose levels that damage the nerves and it's typically going to damage well when you have a chemically induced or opathy it's going to damage the nerves
In the periphery beating the fingers and the hands and the toes and the feet because you know how do you when you have a chemical circulating your body and then it dissipates into the tissues
It's going to have the most difficult time getting out of the peripheral areas because
Of just the location so that chemical it's going to settle there and it could damage those nerves now because of the way your nerves are
There are what are called small diameter afference and large diameter afference
It's the large diameter afference that carry these signals of the of peed in and tingling
That's what's carried on the large diameter afference and they're the most susceptible to damage because of the physical attributes of the nerve sheath
So with
Emo therapy induced or opathy or diabetic induced or opathy glucose levels and being high rates high levels can damage that that large diameter afference pathway which is going to be
You're going to start to feel numbness to glean pain type things
Well, then what do you do so you have to a work on trying to pull out that chemical?
How do you do that? Well, that's where using the iron pro wave on your hands so you run the iron pro wave putting your hands in the bucket can be helpful
Using magnesium baths if your hands just putting your hands in an epsom salt bath in a little bucket can be helpful
Saunas make sure you're getting your hands in the sauna so that you're sweating through your hands can be helpful.
Your lymphatic drainage hold your hands above your head and make sure you're exercising and moving it so you move that chemistry out of there.
But if you what do you do once there's already damage to those nerve pathways well that you have to stimulate those nerve pathways to heal and you might be looking at wanting to get that tool called the rebuilder.
So the rebuilder is the apparatus that is was created specifically for neuropathy it's separate from the from the true right it is FDA approved has got tons of studies on it for benefiting people with the
rapidity of any kind of any type so it's if you look on our website it's called the rebuilder.
It's called rebuilder 300 I'll pull up a picture of it for you and so you can see what it looks like but it looks like a little tens unit but it's very different than a tens unit it's the way it it's the way it works in the way it fires into your hand.
Hands are your feet you also have a bucket of water but it has to be a split buckets you have to go to there's information on our store about the rebuilder itself so you can look at that.
But I literally we've sold dozens and dozens and dozens of these for a decade we sold these for a long time and people had a really good success with them.